[Music]
hi my name is Katja I'm a researcher in
the machine intelligence group at MSR
Cambridge I'm presenting project model
project model is an AI experimentation
platform that is open-source and that my
team did on top of the game minecraft to
make it as easy as possible to develop
and experiment with agents that are
embodied within the game minecraft we
see project memo as a stepping stone
toward real-world applications and we
are particularly interested in how it
can push in to specific directions first
we are very interested in this question
of how agents can learn to collaborate
with each other and with human players
recently we conducted the first
collaborative ki mano collaborative AI
challenge where participants were tasked
to develop an agent that could learn to
collaborate in a pig chase task so I can
briefly show that here in this task we
see two agents the blue and the red
agent that are trying to catch a pig
together the pig has shown over here we
can see this either in this top-down
view here or in this first-person view
that you see over here so I can look
around and see my collaborator here and
if this collaborator is able to
collaborate effectively then I can go
and catch the pig right here this game
encapsulate some really interesting
challenges challenges and how we can
infer intents of other agents and how
those inferred intents or our beliefs
over their plans and their strategy
can inform the actions that we or the AI
agent should take in via challenge task
participants graduate student teams
participated from across the world we
had more than 80 teams participating and
what was really interesting to me was
that they came up with widely different
approaches to this problem we're
currently soliciting defect if you have
any ideas on what kinds of tasks would
be interesting to conduct within the
model platform we would be very
interested to hear about that
the mano platform is very open-ended and
supports the wide range of research and
tasks if you feel like trying it out
it's available on github
try it out today